hey there don't you hate it when you
feel depressed alright
lighting equipment ahead I'm ready to
film you know if you're depressed go
talk to someone tell a friend seek out a
professional Thanks you always know what
to say to make me feel better
although do you really have to be it now
I personally always feel like I'm torn
between eternally optimistic and
borderline sad Abraham Lincoln once said
that everyone is only as happy as they
make up their minds to be and to a
certain extent he's right I mean we're
not out in the world battling for our
survival
too busy worrying about life or death to
even contemplate sadness dinner in
modern society life has kind of become
one big mental battle oh my god you
should be so depressed I mean look at
you you're like a worthless piece of
shit and I should know because I'm you
and I'm telling you you want to know
what happened to the last motherfucker
fucked with me just be very calm I'm
just gonna go in this closet okay
I'm never gonna come out again I'm
really sorry I mean maybe midlife crisis
you'll see me again but who know
but seriously if you're depressed go
talk to a friend and if you don't have
any friends and that's why you're
depressed keep a gratitude journal like
Carol shares that I'll share some of
mine
like I'm grateful I woke up today right
simple but yeah I'm grateful I woke up
today I'm grateful for food because
whoever doesn't like food is fucking
dead I am grateful for all the
opportunities that have come my way I'm
grateful for my cats I'm grateful for
Ray's penis I'm grateful that I get to
end this episode on a dick joke see
life's better already
stay off in Gotham I don't know I mean I
feel like I have no reason to be
depressed my therapist just walked away
from me and I'm satisfied
oh and I'd love to share with you guys
yesterday we finally started filming a
new sketch series I've created called so
fetch sketch I want to say a special
thank you to Pavan NYC they supplied our
wardrobe and so you'll see some crazy
outfits in the episodes I got to work
with such amazing amazing artists and
I'm so thankful to everyone who helped
collaborate on that project and make it
I'm editing it right now and it
premieres Wednesday October 3rd on the
so fetch sketch channel so really
excited yay thank you thank you one step
at a time